[Music]
all right some lighter news now to
sports the vegas golden knights need
just
eight more wins to bring home a stanley
cup tonight the team had the chance to
start round three off the play
off in the playoffs in the big way now
but dallas had other plans john treach
is here now with a recap of game one
john yeah game one of the western
conference final will not be entered
into a beauty pageant
it was a battle of two tired teams
trying to survive instead of thrive
and leaves golden knights fans and a
highlight segment wanting more western
conference final bowl stars and knights
coming off a game seven a rugged one
mark andre fleury in net and the first
shot he sees
goes into the back of the net one
nothing less than three minutes
into the conference final not ideal
fleury would
not allow another goal he buckled down
unfortunately for the punchless golden
knights
they didn't get close to scoring not a
lot of offensive excitement for vegas as
they are shut
out fleury saved 96 percent of the shots
he faced and it wasn't
enough one nothing in zero was the
amount of spark in the golden knights
tonight it just took us too long to get
into the game it took us too long to get
that
that energy that fire that that bravado
that you need to play in these types of
games
in the final four i mean every team is
good here dallas is a good team
you know there's two teams are good
teams you know we're a good team
you see what we've done the last couple
weeks but you know
when it comes down to the last four
teams it's anybody's ballgame you know
and
you can you got to be you got to be able
to be on your toes from the top of the
puck to
to be successful here just one game now
game two will be coming quickly on
tuesday hopefully the gold knights can
locate offense in time for the 5 pm
start we'll